hey guys recently HBO has released
stills from Game of Thrones season 7
premiere episode which along with
recently released titles and
descriptions gave us rather a few huge
hints regarding the first episode of the
seventh season the first episode that
will premiere on Sunday night is named
Dragonstone and as HBO confirmed that it
will run for 59 minutes a description
for this episode there stated that Jon
organizes the defense of the north
Cersei choice leaving the odds and the
nurse comes home new stills that have
recently been released didn't show much
but it certainly did confirm a few
highly expected events that will take
place in the first episode while the
official trailer confirmed that bran
stark will arrive at Winterfell at some
point of the upcoming season and you
still from episode 1 that includes Nina
Reed revealed that bran and his
long-standing friend and protector will
finally cross or at least arrive at the
wall in the very first episode this shot
that includes the Lord said accompanied
with a few brothers of the Nights Watch
is most likely taking a few moments
before a shot in which the acting Lord
Commander accompanied with the same man
is welcoming Meera is not only that he's
accompanied with the same brothers but I
also don't expect anyone else to arrive
at the wall at least not in the same
episode there are also few stills from
King's Landing in which we can see a
person painting a giant map of Westeros
in the red cape for his queen or the
next shot contains the Queen herself
Cersei is standing on the same map with
a glass of wine they're almost certainly
be a few scenes that will include Cersei
and Jaime Lannister planning their
battles over a dozens of feet long giant
map of Westeros as it's been stated in
description of this episode sirs will
try to even the odds by making new
alliances which will firstly in the
first episode be with Randall and his
house Tarly autumn at queen and her
brother are deliberating have to make
her reign last a bit longer
now that Daenerys supported it a few
allies has finally arrived at Westeros
with her dragons at her armies we also
have a few shots from Winterfell that
are once again confirming a few events
that will take place over there in the
first episode we have the shot that
includes Jon Snow's most trusted Ally
lady Lee in a moment this shot is once
again confirming that in the very first
episode of the upcoming season there
will be a huge meeting in Winterfell
that will attend obviously the king in
the north himself all northern Lords and
other important people this meeting will
determine of treasons
House says that betrayed them by
supporting the Bolton's which I can tell
for sure since one promotional photo
confirmed an appearance of Ellis
Karstark as we got to see an actress
Megan Parkinson as I said in previous
video appearance of Ellis Karstark in
the upcoming season is not that
surprising at all since Parkinson's
agency has confirmed her appearance in
the seventh season of Game of Thrones a
few months ago
long story short Ellis Karstark is
daughter of Rickard Karstark and his an
heir of house Karstarks since her father
and two brothers died a long time ago
but her only remaining brother Harold
will either be executed or sent to the
wall for his betrayal this meeting that
will most likely result with Jon Snow's
refusal to hold Ellis responsible for
her brother's betrayal has also been
hinted by the official description of
the first episode as their stated john
organizes the defense of the north
meaning that beside the determining fate
of treasonous norton houses the king in
the north also discussed the threat of
the night King and his undead army with
other northern Lords Jon Snow Boleyn
says that they need to start mining
obsidian a form of volcanic glass which
is beside Valyrian steel the only known
substance capable of killing White
Walkers well it's also important to
highlight that large amounts of it can
be found on Dragonstone Island John
knows that dragon glass is more valuable
than gold and it will be one of the main
reasons that will lead him to leave
Winterfell for Dragonstone a bit later
dragon stone will be the place to meet
John engineers who meet for the very
first time
even though Jon Snow's main intention
will not be just to meet Daenerys but
rather to try to collect as much dragon
glass as he can as well as to try to
persuade Dany to send her armies and
dragons to the north there are also few
stills from the first episode that
includes Daenerys which is not
surprising as it's already been
confirmed a long time ago by a bunch of
promotional photos that Dany will arrive
at Dragonstone as the last statement in
the official description as well as the
title of the first episode says itself
Daenerys will finally come home at
Dragonstone an island which is the
location of the castle of Dragonstone
the ancestral seat of House Targaryen
the nearest was born in Dragonstone and
after six seasons of preparations she
will now finally arrive home with her
two large armies three dragons and with
the support of a few powerful allies
while the huge meeting in Winterfell
brands and mirrors arrival at the wall
as well as Dana's arrival at Dragonstone
are the main
events of the season 7 premiere there
will doubtlessly be much more to see
tomorrow we'll be introduced with a
theory that is not only highly possible
to happen but also to take place in the
first episode and